president zielinski has promised that
Ukraine will find the Russians allegedly
responsible for shooting dead and
unarmed Ukrainian Soldier footage
emerged online yesterday purportedly
showing the killing and a warning that
we're about to show the moments leading
up to that incident in it an unarmed man
is seen smoking a cigarette before
saying glory to Ukraine
the man is then shot repeatedly Sky News
has been unable to independently verify
the location and date of the footage but
Ukraine says the man killed is thought
to be Ukrainian serviceman called
Timothy shadora who went missing in the
area around the heavily contested city
of bakmut in early February
a video appeared today showing how the
occupiers brutally killed a soldier who
bravely said to their face glory to
Ukraine I want all of us together in
unity to respond to his words glory to
the hero glory to Heroes glory to
Ukraine and we will find the killers
well our chief correspondent Stuart
Ramsey has more now from Keith
there's some confusion about the detail
of the video what I would say though if
it is absolutely uh correct and what it
purports to be then that is without
doubt a war crime and of course that's
nothing to do with actual uh fighting as
we're saying around back mood and in
other parts of the country as well that
is just simply a criminal act and and it
will be investigated there are of course
hundreds if not thousands of War crime
allegations that are being investigated
uh right now from the rape of women from
the killing of civilians and Justice
shooting and damage course for civilian
buildings I think the key issue here
though is despite what the President
says I don't know how you're going to
find the people who carried out that
attack that will be extremely difficult
but he says that is what they're going
to attempt to do and we know that the
prosecutors here are following on and
all sorts of of crimes in the UN of
course are doing exactly the same but it
will be very difficult I think very
interesting when it comes to war crimes
is what they're really interested in
that's the invest Educators is to worse
the the line of command with their
actual orders uh to do this and how high
up to those orders uh go did they go all
the way up to the Kremlin for example
for some of the behavior that we've seen
uh in the country and what is turning
into a really really nasty War as We
Know
um Sean your reaction to that video and
any more detail that you you can tell us
about it yeah it's part of the horrors
of War that's being piped in our living
room which is quite horrible but what
what do we know this is a 12 second
video it's not a particularly great a
great quality it appears to show a
Ukrainian Soldier uh a captured prison
of War getting shots at point-blank
range
um now but this is an information War
and the harsh reality is we don't know
the background to that video so it's
very difficult to provide informed
comment on that specific instant however
the law of armed conflict and the Geneva
Convention are both rules signed up to
by Russia that specifically provide
legal guidance around the handling of
prisoners of War to provide them
protection now Russia uses Wagner group
mercenaries which are not professional
soldiers do not have any professional
training on the lauravan conflict and
Putin pays for these Barn group it also
equips the bardner group through yevgeni
pregosin the boss of the violent group
there so Putin is actually per um
personally accountable for any war
crimes that committed by that group and
the challenge here is that whilst this
one video has emerged and has actually
been released so we've seen it the worry
is how many of these incidents are
happening routinely that we're just not
hearing about it could be the tip of the
iceberg and of course there's been no
the bargaining group has been recruiting
convicts and we have very little access
to the front line it's really hard to
know what's going on um so to broaden it
out Sean
um on that note what is going on on the
ground at the moment as we understand it
especially around that heavily contested
city of back Newt so the fighting has
been continuing although it seems to be
abating to the North and South a bit but
around back moot the sort of noose
tightening around the Ukrainian forces
there Ukrainian position was looking a
bit a bit precarious 48 hours ago but
the ukrainians seem to have bolstered
their position somewhat look look more
robust but the real question for the
ukrainians is whether they stay and
fight in this Enclave here and risk
getting encircled or do they withdraw
now the American political and Military
advice has been to them to to withdraw
save their limited resources to be able
to fight for another day but president
zielinski has done quite the opposite
he's actually ordered reinforcement of
the Ukrainian position in the middle of
the city here part of that is because
it's his lands it's personal to him but
also if you give up the town of bakmood
it's going to be really really difficult
for them to take it back again but
strategically there's a really
interesting point here that Russia has
mounted a major offensive if its intent
was to take the whole of the donbass
then it's failing miserably and it looks
very likely that the only way that
they're going to be able to achieve
their objective is they have mad
large-scale mobilization not only of its
people but its economy and also its
industry to do that it's effectively
putting Russia onto a war footing and
Putin will judge that the Russian
population may not be ready for that
just yet yeah and we saw just how
unpopular that was last time when people
called mobilization Sean for now thanks
so much